Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
В прошлом уроке мы поговорили с вами о WebGPU.
О том, как можно определить использование виртуальной машины,
определить использование антидетекта, виртуального сервера,
или же выделенного сервера с помощью технологии WebGPU.
Однако мы на этом не останавливаемся.
Точнее, на этом не останавливаются исследователи антифрод-систем.
И сегодня я покажу вам, что такое отпечаток WebGPU,
как он формируется, какие есть методики его подмены.
Итак, когда дело касается отпечатка WebGPU,
большинство пользователей вспоминают про веб-ресурс BrowserLeaks.
Вот он перед вами.
И они воспринимают вот этот отпечаток, вот этот хэш,
точнее, как отпечаток WebGPU, действительно реальный.
Но на самом деле этот хэш не имеет к отпечатку WebGPU ничего общего.
Объясню почему.
Если мы нажмем здесь на JSON-дамп,
то мы видим, какую информацию собирает данный веб-ресурс нашего ПК,
и, соответственно, затем он преобразует ее в удобный машиночитабельный хэш,
который мы видим сейчас перед собой.
И при унификации такого подхода, то есть каждая видеокарта,
каждый пользователь со своей видеокартой, когда придет на этот веб-ресурс,
он будет видеть один и тот же отпечаток.
Потому что данная, в данном случае, даже модель,
где она находится,
модель видеокарты не используется, не раскрывается.
А все остальные константы, которые мы видим сейчас,
которые ответственны за обработку графики,
они являются одинаковыми на большинстве видеокарт.
То есть вы не отличите видеокарту третьего семейства от видеокарты четвертого семейства,
или же видеокарту первого семейства от видеокарты десятого, точнее семейства от шестнадцатого.
Что же делать в таком случае?
Есть, наверняка, какой-то отпечаток.
Я вам сейчас про него расскажу.
В июне месяце 2025 года, то есть совершенно недавно,
на выставке V-Sec в США
была представлена технология,
которая позволяет создать действительно реальный отпечаток WebGPU.
И более того, вам скажу,
технология невероятно простая,
и она призвана заменить собой устаревший уже отпечаток WebGL,
который, как я и говорил вам ранее,
он уже использоваться фактически веб-ресурсами не будет.
Технология мертва.
Она дальше развиваться не будет.
Если кого-то интересует данный документ,
вы можете загуглить, либо же просто обратиться к нашему курсу,
к хранилищу файлов и увидеть там данный документ
с его полной технической характеристикой.
Но нужно показать, как это работает по факту.
Есть такая страничка нашего чекера.
Вы можете также ее найти на сайте DetectExpert.
И здесь у нас имеется WebGPU Atomic Fingerprint.
То, о чем мы сейчас с вами и будем говорить.
Что это такое и зачем нам это нужно?
Дело в том, что в работе в WebGL,
когда мы смотрели, как работает WebGL,
мы понимали, что там производится какой-то рендеринг графики.
Но этот рендеринг графики можно было в принципе
без особых усилий подделать.
Чем, собственно говоря, пользовались браузерные антидетекты.
Что же с WebGPU?
Наша задача сейчас нажать на кнопку Collect Fingerprint.
И вот мы получаем наш фингерпринт.
Как мы видим, я сейчас хочу показать отдельный небольшой тест,
который очень важен будет по поводу загрузки.
Давайте посмотрим.
Давайте посмотрим сейчас на загрузку GPU при проведении данного теста.
Вот мы видим, что сейчас у нас уровень загрузки держится на уровне 40-50%
и да, плюс-минус в этих пределах.
Если мы нажимаем с вами, обновим страницу,
нажимаем на кнопку Collect Fingerprint,
мы не видим фактически никаких изменений сейчас на нашем графике.
То есть обнаружить данный тест невероятно сложно.
В его техническом плане.
Плюс ко всему этот тест не является, скажем так, ресурсоемким.
И это большой плюс для него, но большой минус для нас.
Как работает данный тест? Как происходит вычисление?
Мы запускаем так называемые Compute Shaders WebGPU.
И в этих шейдерах множество потоков параллельно делают так называемую процедуру Atomic Add.
По общему счету.
Поэтому этот называется, собственно, отпечаток у нас WebGPU Atomic Fingerprint.
И ваш GPU-планировщик, который находится на вашем ПК,
ваш физический тот, скажем так, элемент, который управляет вашей видеокартой и распределением ресурсов,
он распределяет эти ресурсы между потоками для вычисления вот этих Compute Shaders.
И благодаря тому, что на разных видеокартах,
этот планировщик отличается, плюс ко всему,
планировщик GPU имеет также отличие в драйверах.
То есть, иными словами, есть возможность отличить новые драйвера от старых драйверов.
И благодаря тому, что на разных системах этот планировщик будет работать по-разному,
в разных видеокартах, я имею в виду,
есть возможность вычислить пользователя, идентифицировать пользователя с невероятно высоким показателем.
И если говорить о точности, 70%.
70% не стоит думать, что это как-то мало.
Это действительно отличный показатель в данном случае.
Объясню почему.
Потому что при комбинации с дополнительными параметрами,
такими как тест производительности,
такими параметрами, как запрос юзер-агента,
мы можем идентифицировать устройства пользователя и понять, какой пользователь находится перед нами.
Плюс ко всему, данный тест великолепнейшим образом позволяет определить,
Имеется ли у нас встроенная видеокарта?
И используются ли ресурсы нашего ноутбука?
Ну, то есть, если мы используем ноутбук, а не десктопный ПК.
В частности, как обойти использование данного теста?
Использование данного теста, точнее технологию, которая используется в данном тесте,
можно обойти несколькими различными путями.
Некоторые из них правильные, некоторые неправильные.
Неправильные пути заключаются в том, что можно путем модифицирования исходного кода самого браузера
изменить распределение потоков.
То есть, иными словами, вместо использования, например, 10 потоков,
будет задана константа использования 12 потоков или 8 потоков.
Условно, я сейчас не буду к конкретным цифрам привязываться.
Данная технология, данная методика обхода этой технологии не является верной,
но, тем не менее, будет применима в ближайшее время на популярных публичных чекерах.
Ведь всего-навсего в несколько простейших операций можно обойти данную технологию.
Но я призываю вас не верить всему, что вы увидите на чекерах.
Объясню почему. Потому что рандомизация данного отпечатка,
если она будет выполнена не ресурсами,
а ресурсами браузера,
она великолепнейшим образом будет видна.
Потому что будет видно, какое количество потоков было задействовано в выполнении той или иной операции.
Каким образом можно данную операцию обмануть легально?
Как вы понимаете уже,
наш web gpu планировщик, точнее gpu планировщик, который использует технологию web gpu нашего браузера,
он чувствителен к режимам
распределения питания, это первое. Второе, к настройкам текущей видеокарты и, что немаловажно, к
настройкам работы в одном определенном приложении.
Иными словами, когда вы проверяете,
через, например, nvidia geforce control panel, когда вы проверяете какое-либо приложение, вы можете выдать ему ресурсы максимальной производительности,
либо же
максимальной визуальной составляющей.
Распределение, изменение распределения ресурсов в данном приложении,
в данном случае, будет влиять на то, как будет формироваться данный отпечаток.
Простыми словами, вы просто дали этому браузеру, например, больше ресурсов, у вас этот отпечаток изменился.
Можно поступить таким образом, можно поступить образом, немного другим, путем модификации
самих драйверов. Это более сложный вариант и применим он в большинстве случаев больше всего в
виртуальных машинах, потому что использование таких изменений на реальной машине может навредить вашей системе
и, плюс ко всему, вам придется переподписывать драйвера, что для пользователей сейчас не является актуальным.
Текущая версия, которую вы можете видеть сейчас на своих экранах, состоит всего-навсего из
небольшого количества строчек кода. Если мы посмотрим, здесь у нас всего-навсего
553 строчки, плюс еще вместе с оформлением. То есть, иными словами, данный нересурсоемкий
тест может находиться фактически на любом веб-ресурсе и
не замечено.
Есть ли какие-либо варианты
определения того, что используется данная технология? По факту, конечно же, есть. Это просто проверка через исходный код,
например,
навигатор GPU.
Если мы видим вот эту строчку, значит у нас, конечно же, используется технология веб-GPU. Но если исходный код скриптов,
либо же самой веб-страницы был обфусцирован, то мы можем не увидеть
такую строчку. Поэтому лично от себя, лично от себя, я рекомендую сделать следующее. Если у вас нет какого-либо
серьезного
деобфускатора кода, то проверить просто эффективность свою,
проверить свою эффективность путем отключения поддержки веб-GPU.
В том случае, если вы, например,
не уверены, что веб-ресурс использует данную технологию или не использует, или же у вас с ней
нет системы подмены. Как только система подмены у вас заработает, например, при использовании моего антидетектора, либо при использовании
браузерных антидетекторов, когда они реализуют данный функционал, тогда вы можете, в принципе,
вот эту опцию отключения, полного отключения веб-GPU забыть. На текущий момент хотелось бы
закончить следующим, что технология веб-GPU, в частности, вот этот отпечаток,
являются новейшими.
Если сама технология еще даже находится в
стадии экспериментов, потому что мы видим сейчас On-Safe Web-GPU Support, как нам и сообщает Chrome,
приблизительно к сентябрю-октябрю месяцу текущего года технология перестанет быть
экспериментальной и войдет уже в стабильную фазу, то отпечаток, который мы с вами увидели,
заработает фактически сразу же с
полной стабилизацией технологии веб-GPU. Соответственно, мы можем ожидать его использования на веб-ресурсах уже в
октябре-ноябре
текущего года,
что
довольно-таки
недалеко от нас, и поэтому вам нужно обязательно
знать об этом отпечатке, поскольку, если вы будете, например, в своем браузере
заявлять, что вы используете, например, видеокарту Nvidia RTX 2080, а по факту работаете на
ВПС-ке с антидетект браузером, где у вас вообще видеокарты нет, и, соответственно, этот тест будет проходить на
данных своих параметрах,
ну, в таком случае у вас могут быть проблемы с антифродом. Поэтому рекомендую сохранить себе данную информацию и
обязательно ознакомиться с кодом данного теста,
потому что нигде его сейчас вы не найдете. Это не какая-то,
скажем так, это не какой-то публичный чекер, взятый из гитхаба. В данном случае этот чекер был написан мной.
Так что на основании исследований, которые прошли в июне месяце,
самая свежайшая информация о реальном, действительном отпечатке WebGPU перед вами.
Обратите на нее внимание, потому что к концу года, текущего 25 года, она вам очень понадобится. Спасибо за внимание, с вами был Vector T13.